so far we see no indication that this
was a plot directed from outside the
United States and we see no indication
that he was part of any kind of network
it is also not entirely clear at this
point just what terrorist group he
aspired to support although he made
clear his affinity at the time of the
attack for ISIL and generally leading up
to the attack for radical Islamist
groups
he made 911 calls from the club during
the attack at about 2:30 in the morning
Sunday morning and there were three
different calls he called and he hung up
he called again and spoke briefly with
the dispatcher and then he hung up and
then the dispatcher called him back
again and they spoke briefly so there
were 3 total calls during the calls he
said he was doing this for the leader of
ISIL who he named and pledged loyalty to
but he also appeared to claim solidarity
with the perpetrators of the Boston
Marathon bombing and solidarity with a
Florida man who died as a suicide bomber
in Syria for al-nusra front a group in
conflict with the so-called Islamic
state the Bombers at the Boston Marathon
and the suicide bomber from Florida were
not inspired by ISIL which adds a little
bit to the confusion about his motives
and of course we're working to
understand what role anti-gay bigotry
may have played in motivating this
attack an attack that occurred during
the very month when we recognize and
celebrate our LGBT brothers and sisters
again it's early we're working hard to
understand the killer and his motives
and his sources of inspiration but we
are highly confident that this killer
was radicalized
and at least in some part through the
internet so that's what we've been doing
now let me tell you what I can about the
FBI's prior contact with the killer we
first became aware of him in May of 2013
he was working as a contract security
guard at a local courthouse and he made
some statements the
were inflammatory and contradictory that
concerned his co-workers about terrorism
first he claimed family connections to
al Qaeda he also said that he was a
member of Hezbollah which is a Shia
terrorist organization that is a bitter
enemy of the so-called Islamic state
ISIL he said he hoped that law
enforcement would raid his apartment and
assault his wife and child so that he
could martyr himself when this was
reported to us
the FBI's Miami office opened a
preliminary investigation and over the
next 10 months we attempted to determine
whether he was possibly a terrorist
something we do in hundreds and hundreds
of cases all across the country
our investigation involved introducing
confidential sources to him recording
conversations with him following him
reviewing transactional records from his
communications and searching all
government Holdings for any possible
connections any possible derogatory
information we then interviewed him
twice
he admitted making the statements that
his co-workers reported but explained
that he did it in anger because he
thought his co-workers were
discriminating against him and teasing
him because he was Muslim after 10
months of investigation we closed the
preliminary investigation two months
later in July of 2014 the killer's name
surfaced again in an indirect way our
Miami office was investigating the
Florida man who had blown himself up for
the misra front in Syria again the nusra
front being an al-qaida group in
conflict with ISIL and we learned from
the investigation that the killer knew
him casually from attending the same
mosque in that area of Florida but our
investigation turned up no ties of any
consequence between the two of them in
the course of that investigation one
witness told us when asked do you know
anybody else who might be radicalizing
that he had once been concerned about
the killer because the killer had
mentioned a lakh evideos
but that the witness had concluded that
he later got married and had a child and
got a job as a security guard and so he
was no longer
about him our investigation again turned
and interviewed the killer to find out
whether he had any significant contacts
with the suicide bomber from the surra
determined that he did not and then the
inquiry continued focusing on the
suicide bomber with no further focus on
the Orlando killer we will continue to
look forward in this investigation and
backward we will leave no stone unturned
and we will work all day and all night
to understand the path to that terrible
night we're also going to look hard at
our own work to see whether there is
something we should have done
differently so far the honest answer is
I don't think so I don't see anything in
reviewing our work that our agents
should have done differently but we'll
look at it in an opah stand open an
honest way and be transparent about it